I I think we do have a responsibility
and i' I tried to use my social media
for good uh to show that there are two
sides of the same coin and it's not all
roses and you know I I'll post pictures
that I don't even like of myself because
I'm I want to be real and that's the
same with filters I think like I've been
very mindful of not using filters in
fact actually weirdly Drew my bdd when I
was really bad I actually would post
without filters cuz then I thought
that's my real stuff that's how I get
Foundation um but I also think now like
this day and age especially on Tik Tok
the filters just look so real and you
don't really know if it's real or not so
people just scrolling down are going to
think oh that's why am I not like that
why do I not look like that